[Music]
we're kind of the special school that
you can't see the disability of it you
can't see the trauma as a physical thing
you see the behavior that comes from it
[Applause]
it's all right what happens we get a lot
of um
children who have been abused whether
that be
mentally physically sexually there's
lots of different abuse
do you enjoy this school
i just think this place
is a more easier a better place for me
this is an extraordinary place
a second home to some of the most
vulnerable and troubled children in
society
rejected by a mainstream education
system that just can't handle them i
think we take for granted the level of
trauma that a lot of the kids have
experienced
the good news is that there are special
schools like this one that can help
and they're making a difference
stupid idiotic punk the bad news is that
there's not nearly enough of them and
more and more are closing what do you
think happens to kids who actually don't
manage to get to a place like this very
often they get lost in the system almost
and the parents face an uphill struggle
to find the help they desperately need
they're not getting the education
they're not getting the support there's
not the provisions there in place and
there's so many forgotten children
[Music]
you never know what you're going to get
on any given day because you don't know
what's happened the night before you
don't know what's happened that morning
on the way to school so i think all of
the staff would agree that there's
always that underlying level of of
anxiety of what's today going to bring
this special school um caters for young
people that's primary need is scmh which
is social emotional or mental health
difficulties
i can completely understand why people
see lots of our types of kids as
troublemakers but that's because they're
troubled i don't definitely don't see
them as troublemakers morning
i see them as kids that need support
they need help
and in terms of kind of where the kids
are coming from is it all local
no no so we've got quite a few kids that
do come from red bridge i'd say maybe
sort of 50-ish 55 percent of them but
then the others come from
far and wide so you've got havering
barking and dagnam newham enfield
essex so some of these kids are in a cab
for like an hour and a half but they
don't get here there's just not enough
schools there's not enough smh schools
we've had one parent emailing this
morning already to say that the child's
had a meltdown at home trying to
strangle the parent
kicked off quite badly and yet the kids
then got in the cabin come to school
she's not quite sure what you're gonna
get when the young person gets here
because they've had quite a traumatic
experience and meltdown already
sydney's been here for i think he's
coming up for three years born in sydney
he was um in mainstream obviously before
he came here and just couldn't cope with
the fact there's 30 children in the
classroom basically
he's not had to be restrained now for
about 18 months and it was like five to
six times a day he was having to
restrain him um because either hurting
somebody else or hurting himself through
frustration
so many children don't get the support
that they need and there's not enough of
these schools around unfortunately and
they're limited spaces
so there's probably
hundreds and hundreds of children just
in this area that need to be in a
special needs school like this and not
mainstream but they just don't get the
opportunity
they're not getting that opportunity
because these types of special schools
are full to the brim
perfect so if you just make sure he
comes to school to do his exam when
you're finished at the police station
that would be great
they're having to turn away way more
kids than they're taking in
what i do know is that demand for that
kind of provision is increasing and what
ends up being the case is if children
don't get the help they need early it
escalates and it becomes crisis point
can i give you the list sorry
the reason for the increase in demand is
that more and more children are
suffering from mental health problems
there's been a 25 rise since the start
of the pandemic
anything to declare
it's harder to get in here than it is to
get through customs
we've got 40 places in primary and 40
places in secondary we have
consultations come through regularly
i've had six come through this week and
we're full so
i mean i think last year was about 130
637 this year is higher than last year
that you just have to turn away yeah and
we have kids that have come here that
have been waiting for a place in a
school like this that haven't been in
school for 18 months 20 months how
different is this place to a mainstream
school you couldn't even compare you
just couldn't compare
[Music]
the deputy head has been called to check
on one of the younger peoples
he's been causing some problems
oh
what happened i hate my life that's why
hmm what's happened i hate my life come
over here
let me pick you up what's happened i
hate my life why because i hate my life
hmm i thought we were going out we had a
little plan for today what was the plan
let's get into your castle and find out
shall we
something's happened he's
throwing things around the room yeah
you're saying i hate my life yes and
then we've just talked about
taking fault for mom and dad he's going
to dad's house this weekend one photo
from mum one vote for dad and just like
that he's back engaged and he'll spend
half an hour doing that now and be
settled
hopefully he'll be fine for the day but
minutes later the same pupil appears to
be struggling
[Applause]
[Applause]
and that kid was so annoying
he's in year four yes eight yeah he
seemed quite distressed there he was
very distressed um he can
become very volatile and very violent um
and then he can just switch it in two
seconds like you saw and sit with you
and talk about anything be the sweet
category yeah yeah but it's his way of
listen listening listen to me no one's
listening to me that's what he felt like
we'll just see the end of p
this can often be a trigger
[Music]
[Applause]
unfortunately a lot of the kids that we
have here will just be excluded and sent
home that would happen a number of times
to the point where the placement's
terminated and they can't go there
anymore they're either permanently
excluded or the school is that it's not
an appropriate setting it's very very
very very rarely do we exclude
particularly here our exclusion rate
even compared to special schools is is
nearly non-existent because if we
exclude them here where do they go well
that's what that's what was thinking
this is kind of the end of the line in
terms of the education system for the
business we're especially deals with
highly complex kids there's no other
school for young people living at home
with their families to come to if this
doesn't work
[Music]
at the end of the day when i leave i
appreciate the silence for a little
while
because it can be loud it can be busy
and i think lots can happen in a day
so you just need a moment to reflect
and as i'm driving home i just like to
just sort of rewind my day
i don't there's a member of staff here
that would say that they can't take
their work home with them
when you're dealing with people's lives
when you've got young people many of
whom are so damaged
you can't help but think about that
[Music]
and these the trophies
oh this is cooper's yeah
what's that for he's got that for chess
i've come to meet a parent of one of the
pupils at the school
and he didn't understand no and he was
just
and then he starts kicking he starts
kicking things and
it was like a jekyll and hyde
but this is what he'd be like at school
as well so how do you expect a
mainstream skull being able to handle
someone being like this
we had a fight to get cooper in his
provision
when cooper gets in from school and i
say how's your day been he says good
cooper would never say anything like
that because he was always being kicked
out of school the conditions he has like
adhd and autism
as well as a few others if you could
take away all of those conditions would
you
no
no wouldn't cooper's copper and
we're in it through thick and thin and
as he's growing up he's turning into a
lovely young man i wouldn't change him
for the world
the swings where all the trouble begins
on top of the slide lays the king of the
castle full of all the dirty rascals in
the cage the football is played it's
just an ordinary special needs school
and in charge of it all mr walter stands
tall mr reese the retired beast this per
shell the irish devil it's just an
ordinary specialty school
what was your old school like
i didn't really learn a lot there
because they didn't have their
requirements to help me with my special
needs
aside this school is good what special
what special needs do you have cooper uh
adhd autism and asperger's i think
how would you feel about having those
conditions
well i mean if i act [ __ ] i'll just
use them like
i'm autistic
yeah i use my autism as a advantage
do you yeah
what is autism
i don't know you just act different to
the rest
that's what my mom says i guess
being a foster kid myself i think it
helps you to realize that you just need
someone to give you a chance a bit of a
timeout a second chance a fifth chance
100th chance
to put things right and try again and
that's what we do here
but do you understand now that when we
go out at break time that we're not
going to be physically touching one
another when we're playing
yesterday
thank you very much let's go back to
class
i don't even know what the time is
we know things about the young people
about their lives about their likes
their dislikes about you know what they
want if they like to be you know soothed
by a stroke on the shoulder if they
don't want to be touched we know quite
intimate details about the young people
as i'm walking up and down it's
beautiful sometimes to see how you've
got eight really complex kids sitting in
a class doing their math gcse so you get
really lovely moments and then you get
moments where you've got young people
that just aren't managing was it super
bad or just a little bit bad
what
how many times
actually when you invest a little bit of
time with those young people to work out
why it is they're not managing
the story starts to sort of unravel
ezra's come on a long way since you
started haven't you yeah my baby was
getting way
better i think a lot of the time kids
are just seeing sort of naughty
kids but it's not there's a lot more
there's a lot more to it than that i
think we take for granted the level of
trauma that a lot of the kids have
experienced and that that trauma those
adverse experiences it's not just
that they've had one or two of those a
lot of these kids have had three four
five of those and the staff here are
fantastic i might have been bitten
yesterday i may have been kicked
yesterday every day starts again
you often find a queue outside my door
and when something's going on
one thing that everybody uses is emojis
and it's brilliant because when they're
sitting there and they're describing how
they feel but they don't really know
what it is they can just point and i
think i've had students before who are
complete mutes and they just point a
point and point and you could do a whole
therapy session without talking just
with the emojis what do you think
happens to kids who actually don't
manage to get to a place like this um
i think they get
very
badly misunderstood i think they end up
in quite dark places because they feel
like they're constantly being judged or
there's nowhere to go they feel like
there's there's no root for them
very often they get lost in the system
almost and their behavior then
starts to get worse because they're not
being understood they're not being
helped
there are of course some brilliant
examples of schools that do an amazing
job and
they're an inspiration but also really
important because they show you
what can be achieved but
they remain the exception and we notice
them because they are exceptional
come on gents
it's the last day of school for this
group of year 11. what does that mean
no no no no no
please
no wine if i can't drink wine now put
that back if i can't drink it you can't
drink it
i know miss baby's getting fired yes yes
that i'm getting it i've got money i've
got money thank you very much
bye
come on eric i know it's not the green
man
i'm saying the green man
man then you crossed it
for these kids this school has done its
job
but they are the lucky ones
only one in three manages to get into a
school like this
and their chances are getting slimmer
there's around 350 special schools like
this one in england
10 closed last year and more will follow
this year
the government is planning to create
around 60 more special schools in the
future but that's unlikely to happen in
the next few years
i do think there is a lack of
understanding of
the level of need that some of the young
people out there really really do
require
i think the education system
is not set up
well enough at the moment to be able to
help funnel children succeed
kids that should be getting the highest
quality of education because of their
needs are just falling further behind
because there's not enough places to
provide them with the quality of
education that they need
you